[Música]
hola muchísimas gracias por seguir en la
pantalla de france 24 y bienvenidos a 5
minutos con hoy nos acompaña el doctor
oscar franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y también de la
universidad de erasmus de rotterdam y
asesor científico de france24 doctor
oscar franco muchísimas gracias como ya
es habitual su presencia en france 24
bueno ya están terminando las
cuarentenas y en algunos países ya
comienzan o al regreso a las clases
presenciales en américa latina' se
preparan y méxico se adelanta pero de
manera virtual hay opiniones muy
divididas por estas medidas aún se cree
que los niños no se enferman por comí 19
dr
cada vez tenemos más y más evidencia de
que los niños si se pueden enfermar por
ccoo y 19 también pueden transmitir la
enfermedad a otros pero lo que sí hemos
visto es que tiene tienden a tener unos
cuadros más leves menos complicaciones y
una probabilidad de muerte menor que los
adultos por ejemplo en el reino unido
hasta ahora han fallecido seis niños y
estos niños tenían enfermedades de base
como cáncer o parálisis cerebral por lo
que nos recuerda que es importante
proteger a los niños que están enfermos
y que si se abran los colegios hay que
implementarlo con medidas de
distanciamiento físico y con higiene
doctor y que nuevas informaciones hay
respecto de la manera en la que se puede
presentar 'el hobbit' 19 en los niños
si en la primera semana de septiembre
vimos resultados publicados por el
investigadores del king's college de
londres que utilizaron la aplicación de
rastreo de inglaterra y encontraron que
un tercio de los niños que dieron
positivo para el virus que causa la
enfermedad no tenían síntomas y un 50%
presentaban síntomas que no son los
síntomas clásicos que se han asociado
con la enfermedad como la fiebre o la
tos o la tos persistente lo que se ha
visto es que los niños tienden a
reportar fatiga dolor de cabeza pérdida
de apetito también pueden presentar
fiebre y también pueden presentar dolor
abdominal diarrea y vómito entonces es
importante para los padres estar
pendientes no solamente de los síntomas
clásicos que se han asociado con la
enfermedad ahora hace unos meses
recordemos que se hablaba del síndrome
de kawasaki cuéntenos de qué se trata y
si aún se considera como una
manifestación de kobe 19
si cada vez tenemos más reportes pero
todavía en una proporción muy pequeña de
niños que pueden presentar este cuadro
severo de inflamación lo que se ha
confirmado es que está relacionado con
el cob y 19 y también se ha confirmado
que es parecido a la enfermedad de
kawasaki pero es distinto tiene unos
mecanismos diferentes en términos de
inmunología y de inflamación y se le ha
denominado el síndrome de síndrome multi
inflamatorio sistémico entonces lo que
se ha visto es que los niños pueden
presentar 4 a 6 semanas después de haber
tenido con o bien 19 cosas como por
ejemplo dolor de cabeza dolor de
estómago o vómito que no suele verse con
la enfermedad de kawasaki y hay algún
tipo de explicación acerca de por qué
algunos niños pueden tener una respuesta
inflamatoria tan severa comparado con
otros niños
si el 6 de septiembre vimos una
publicación en la revista ser de un
grupo de investigadores del instituto
karolinska de estocolmo que dice que los
niños con este tipo de respuestas
severas solían tener no en ningún
anticuerpo contra los coronavirus
endémicos los que causan la gripe común
entonces parece que la inmunidad cruzada
podría jugar un papel y que si se ha
estado en presencia de este tipo de
resfriados comunes causados por esos
coronavirus comunes que circulan todos
los años podrían proteger para tener una
respuesta diferente ante el virus que
causa el cob y 19 doctor oscar franco
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france mit y 4 como ya es habitual a
nuestra audiencia le decimos como
siempre que continúen por favor con
todos sus cuidados sigan en france 24 y
en france 24 punto com
[Música]